il ne le décrit me dis pas ça parce que
j'ai bien ri dollars aia non mais à
chaque fois c'est des conneries je ferme
ma gueule dans ses mélodies tout
pourquoi pas compris de quoi évidemment
complexe en arrive à raconter des
conneries et pas du tout dans l'ain
arguments pourquoi tu es probable dit ne
t'emballe pas toi
[Applaudissements]
messieurs conviction retardés la neige
je mets tes couilles sur l'a4
il affiche un
convive est cher c'est vrai j'ai une
conviction s'il vous plaît s'il était
une grosse merde
là
c'est la supplie laissez le parler il
fait son numéro et à l'arrivée c'est bon
c'est bon après mon bac tu disais en
loge je pensais pas ce que disait mais
enfin moi je dis ça donc elle arrête de
mentir c'est bon c'est bon allez
pourquoi vous êtes probable connard
kovacs juste pour ça va parce que le
savoir vivre ensemble s'en sortir a
passé la nuit mais oui c'est gérer sa
liberté envisagea parce que même quand
on dit qu'on va se faire au vaccin en
trois mois ça va pas durer toute la vie
c'est le temps de s'en sortir je te
voyais un pseudo exploit espoirs avec le
micro en disant que c'est moins violent
et c'est donc progressivement s'en sort
donc faut le faire tous ensemble on
tombe alors sentir que j'avais déjà fait
deux ans qu'on nous dit ça il y aura
plus on remet la balle a évolué sans
armes et livia deux ans je l'espère du
regard le crédit à l'extérieur j'ai vu
que celle de l'état le chef de l'état
vous envoyer un message à l'époque ça
regardez bien dire quelque chose à faire
une déclaration emmanuel macron les
non-vaccinés j'ai très envie de les
emmerder donc on va continuer de le
faire jusqu'au bout
c'est donc alain mentionné dans
blueberry voilà c'est d'enlever ces dans
le canard enchaîné exactement à désarmer
les termes c'est pas ça mais si
il n'est pas plus à la télé il appelait
jeu
voilà y'a eu allocation l'ubs agents
j'ai très envie d'emmener les non
vaccinés